this video is made possible by Vince
arrow watches luxury handcrafted watches
fair prices you can check them out
through the link below he was the most
hated among Hitler's inner circle a
thuggish bully who's uncouth ways and
scheming self-interest allowed him to
manipulate his way into a position of
power within the Nazi hierarchy a
settlers personal secretary he became
the Fuhrer as gatekeeper and his most
trusted confidant
in today's by graphics we're examining
the life and the death of Martin Bormann
[Music]
Martin Bormann was born into the
Prussian town of vagabond on June the
17th 1903 door and Antonia were of the
Lutheran faith with Theodore being a
post office worker it was his second
marriage and he already had two children
went Martin came along when Martin was 3
years of age his father he died
Antonia soon remarried the child showed
little interest in his schooling and in
his early teens he dropped out to study
at an agricultural grade high school
those studies they were cut short when
he signed up with the army upon reaching
the age of 18 he joined the 55th field
artillery regiment as a gunner he was
too late to see any action during the
First World War serving garrison duty
until he was discharged from the Army in
February of 1919 Bullman moved Nicklin
bog where he secured a position as a
farm estate manager he also joined a
volunteer group known as the fry Corps
which was formed to guard the local
farms from pillaging the group also
fought against those that were
considered betrayers of Germany during
the war the Communists Bowman was now a
stocky belligerent young man and he
quickly learns the trade of the bully on
March the 17th 1924 Borbon was found
guilty of being an accomplice to the
murder of a fellow fry court member
named walter cat out cat i was believed
to have grossed in another member to the
french authorities for conducting
sabotage operations that man was
subsequently executed by the french in
retaliation Bauman and several others
got a hold of kowtow and took him to an
isolated field where they beat him and
cut his throat Borman spent a year in
prison for the crime being released in
February of 1925 he returned to the farm
job in Mecklenburg and also joined a
paramilitary offshoot of the nationalist
Socialist Workers Party known as the
front Bond
[Music]
in May of 1926 Mormon I left the farm
and moved in with his mother at birth
I'm armed
in early 1927 he joined the Nazi Party
proper he obtained a job with a weekly
newspaper which was edited by a Nazi
Party official before long Bauman was
acting as press manager for the Nazi
Party in the state of Thuringia it was
soon discovered however that he lacked
the public speaking ability for the
position and he was transferred to the
position of business manager in 1928
Bauman moved to Munich where he worked
for the SA Insurance office at that time
the Nazi Party had set up an insurance
scheme to cover members who were injured
in clashes with other political groups
this was necessary because existing
insurance companies they refused to
cover the Nazis Baumann was instrumental
in setting up the internal insurance
scheme it required each party member to
pay a premium payouts to injured parties
they were solely at the discretion of
borne himself the position of power that
came with holding the purse strings for
insurance payouts allowed woman to
establish a reputation as a financial
expert among Nazi Party members it also
caused many who received payouts to feel
personally indebted to him on September
the 2nd 1929 Bhavan married 19 year-old
Gerda Bush Geller was the daughter of a
key Nazi official who was responsible
for settling disputes within the party
Adolf Hitler was regularly in attendance
at the busch house and he was a witness
at the wedding
it was through the bush connection that
Borman was able to come on to the Fury's
radar on January the 30th 1933 Hitler
became Chancellor of Germany this meant
that the various departments of the Nazi
Party became absorbed into the state
system as a result Bauman suddenly found
himself that of work
he approached Hitler's deputy Rudolf
Hess in search of a job has made him his
personal chief of staff he proved
himself to be a valuable asset working
behind the scenes to iron out bickering
within the party he also took care of
mundane routine and organizational
duties allowing us to focus on public
relations and future planning as he
worked tirelessly on bureaucratic
manners Borman took every opportunity to
get close to Hitler by doing so he was
building up his own personal power in
the summer of 1935 he took advantage of
an opportunity to increase his standing
with Hitler when the Fuehrer decided
that he needed to upgrade his holiday
retreat at birches garden Borman was
given the job of overseeing
the remodeling work he was determined to
bring the job in ahead of schedule in
order to score points with Hitler as a
result he pushed the workers
relentlessly and the job was completed
incredibly quickly Edna was pleased with
the work but he had another demand there
were to be no neighbors on the mountain
and it was up to Borman to get rid of
them most of them were simply able to be
bought off but those who refused at the
property confiscated and was sent to a
concentration camp
then when Hitler complains that there
was no shade at his new retreat Borman
rush to have a linden tree brought in
and planted in the pouring rain
Hitler was beginning to view him as a
man who could be relied upon to get
things done
[Music]
through his efficiency hard work
reliability and absolute loyalty Borman
earns hitless trust it was entrusted
with the job of overseeing Hitler's
finances and set up the Adolf Hitler
endowment of German industry this was a
ruse to force industrialists to provide
gifts that ended up lining the pockets
of the Nazi hierarchy with schemes like
this he earns the gratitude of Nazi top
brass because COA stayed in the
backgrounds Bauman was not seen as a
threat to Hitler's henchmen who were
constantly jostling among themselves for
power in fact for them it was easy to
focus only on his inadequacies he was
far from physically imposing being a
rather squat heavyset man he lacked any
of the sophistication required to be a
top player having neither the strength
of personality or the speaking ability
to persuade others all of those who
simply wrote him off would come to
regret this underestimation prams the
best insight we haven't borman's
character comes from Hitler's Reich
Minister for arms and war production
Albert Speer in his 1970 book inside the
Third Reich Speer says the following
most of the powerful men on to Hitler
watched each other jealously like
pretenders to the throne but none of
them recognized a threat in the shape of
trusty bourbon he had succeeded as
representing himself as in significance
while imperceptibly building up his
bastions even among so many ruthless men
he stood out by his brutality and
coarseness he had no culture which might
have put some restraints on him and in
every case he carried out whatever
Hitler had ordered or what he himself
had gathered from Hitler's hints a
subordinate by nature he treated his own
subordinates as if he were dealing with
cows and oxen Mormon suddenly tried to
control his own immediate boss Rudolf
Hess he would only allow others to
access house if he or one of his staff
members were present in March of 1938
Hitler returned to his home country of
Austria Borman accompanied him with a
special task to perform Hitler told him
to buy up his Hitler's childhood home
along with the school that he had
attended this is something Forman did
successfully the month later Borman
organized a special presence of the
Fuhrer to celebrate the leaders 50th
birthday high in the mountains he built
a tea house for Hitler it cost some 30
million marks as treasurer of the Nazi
past Bauman was extremely liberal in
dishing out money he gave 50
and marks each month to the SS for
entertainment expenses nothing was too
much trouble for Hitler's girlfriend Eva
Braun woman would order SIL come to a
perfume and jewelry for her from Paris
despite his lavish spending on behalf of
others Bauman was not so popular among
Hitler's in a circle in fact most people
they detested him yet no friends to
speak of and treated those under him
with a brutish dominance that made on
lookers recoil now just before we get
into the main event today which is of
course the war I want to take a moment
to tell you about Vince Aero watches
look and here's the truth
ya don't need a watch you got a phone
you can check the time super easily
anytime you want but here's the thing
about watches today they're not really
about telling the time at all they're
more kinda like jewelry for many of the
men who don't really wear jewelry like
myself I only wear a wedding band and a
watch so I love having a good looking
watch it's I've in fact a few to choose
from it's something about style it's a
statement about you and what you like
and that sort of thing and in a way for
me it's sort of a connection to the past
I mean to all those great people who
wore wristwatches they didn't have
iPhones to check and III quite like that
historical connection right now I'm
wearing a Vince arrow chronograph as
well as keeping perfect time it's also
got a timer
those three back tiles right there I'll
just do a close-up b-roll shot right
here but they don't just look good they
also serve a function I mean yes your
iPhone also has a timer but it doesn't
look this good doing it does it now I
pick down a watch with a blue and silver
combination but there's loads of options
on their website you'll be sure to find
something that suits your personal style
unlike many other watches on the market
then Sarah clearly it's not about
minimalist style it's more about that
classic good look of a watch like I say
for me I like that historical connection
so here's the thing many of us we could
wear t-shirts and sweatpants to work if
we want it to but we choose not to we
wear a shirt we up our game just because
we can and a great way to do that is
with a Vince arrow watch go check out
the full range below this video through
the link in the description and thanks
to Ventura Watchers for sponsoring let's
get into the war shall we
when war broke out in September of 1939
Hitler insisted the Borman was always
close by ready to do his master's
bidding his role was as deputy to the
deputy Fuhrer Rudolf Hess and the chief
of staff of the fhrer headquarters he
effectively became the middleman between
the Fuhrer and the next level down of
the Nazi hierarchy in May of 1941
borman's star it was suddenly and
unexpectedly elevated rudolf hess
hitler's trusted deputy and head of the
party Chancellery deserted to scotland
by plane in order to open peace
negotiations with the Allies Hitler he
was outraged at the betrayal of Hesse he
had a number of colleagues of
house-arrested as the deputy to the
traitor Borman would have been in danger
himself he did everything he could to
distance himself from Hesse he even
tormented has his wife trying to get her
evicted from her home it was only when
she appealed to Hitler by way of Eva
Braun that the Fuehrer called Bauman off
with the loss of Hesse there was now an
open position at the very top of the
Nazi hierarchy and Hitler was all too
willing to allow Bauman to step into it
Bauman was now closer to hipper than
ever
he became the Fuehrer's constant shadow
always walking a few steps behind but
always present as far as Hitler's
personal view of Bauman goes Speer
relates that he considered him to be a
rogue and a Philistine but he went on to
say that he didn't have anyone more
efficient so there quoted Hitler as
saying I know he will carry out every
order right down to the last detail
and see it through to the end Bauman was
genuinely convinced that Hitler was
Germany's salvation as a result he was
completely dedicated to the fulfillment
of the Fuhrer as goals as the war in the
East progressed he became the gatekeeper
for the generals in their access to
Hitler before reporting to the Fuehrer
they would have to brief Bauman who
would then tell them what not to reveal
to Hitler while Hitler took his water
the nations of Europe Borman waged his
own war within Germany his enemy were
the churches of Christendom
he stated that national socialism and
Christianity are irreconcilable and
proceeded to close churches and arrest
priests at will as it became
increasingly powerful Borman actively
worked to hold back the careers of
others who were a part of Hitler's inner
circle including Goering Goebbels and
Himmler
his tentacles reached into every area of
the regime including the via Marsh where
he actively encouraged young officers to
spy on their superiors wormans asked you
to
towards the enemies of the state the
Jews and Eastern European Slavs was
straight down to the party line they
were useful forced labor but over and
above that they were just better off
dead
he was also opposed to education once
claiming that every educated person is a
future enemy
by 1943 Borman was more than simply a
shadow to the Fuhrer he was also a
subtle manipulator fiercely guarding
access and guiding Hitler towards the
policies that he most favored as well as
a master manipulator Martin Bormann was
a terrible womanizer his marriage was
still intact with his wife eventually
bearing him ten children however he also
had a string of mistresses and fathered
numerous other children he viewed it as
his duty to the German Reich to produce
as many offspring as possible in 1943
Borman fell madly in love with an
actress named mani appearance he decided
that seeing her on the side wasn't
enough and he wanted to have her as his
second wife as a result he wrote a
letter to his actual wife Gerda telling
her about his latest conquest it read
eivol anadi in love with her and took
her against all her resistance now she's
mine and I'm a lucky fellow I feel
incredibly happily married twice over
now I must take double and triple care
that I stay healthy
your Martin his desire to live a
polygamous life was backed up by the
Nazi belief that people of good German
stock should sow their seed as liberally
as possible Gerda simply had no say in
the matter
when it came down to the final solution
to the Jewish Question the euphemism
used for the mass killing of the Jews
Borman made sure that it was never
openly discussed on one occasion when
Himmler telephoned him with a report
that 20,000 Jews had been eliminated in
a week meeting the set target Bauman he
became furious admonishing Himmler to
never discuss such things over the phone
in 1943 Bauman was appointed Atlas
personal secretary with things beginning
to fall apart as far as the war was
concerned the Fuehrer needed borman's
blind loyalty more than ever there was
growing discontent within the Nazi ranks
and Borman he was determined to weed it
out on July the 20th 1944 an attempt was
made to kill Hitler in its wake Borman
he sprung to life
firing off telexes in order to mobilize
the retaliation swift justice was
enacted with more than 200 people being
convicted and subsequently executed some
of these executions they were filmed for
Hitler to view at his leisure the
assassination attempt gave Hitler the
opportunity to crack down on everyone
who opposed him under the direction of
Borman more than 20,000 people would be
executed or sent to concentration camps
over
next nine months for lack of loyalty to
the Fuhrer
Heinrich Himmler the leader of the SS
was the final barrier between Bauman and
Hitler then Hitler promoted Himmler to
the position of supreme army leader
however with the Allies now driving
towards Berlin on two fronts it was a
promotion of dubious merit Bauman had
maneuvered things to bring about the
promotion seeing it as a means to
sideline him lot by early 1945 Bauman
was at the height of his power
having negated the power of Himmler he
was now second only to Adolphe Hitler by
now the writing though it was well and
truly on the wall the Third Reich it was
doomed and even Borman knew it On
January the 16th 1945 Hitler and his
inner circle they moved underground the
Fuehrer bunker was located under the
gardens of the Reich Chancellery
building in the center of Berlin when
his oldest son Martin sent him a letter
in March of 1945 asking if he thought
the war could still be won he replied
that even a dying lion could still
strike out with its paws with the
Russians and the Americans closing in on
Berlin Borman sent out constant messages
for the troops to fight on he wrote now
the capable will be distinguished from
the incapable the born elders have
smashed all obstacles and are supremely
ready for action
Bauman had made plans to fly Hitler out
of Berlin on his 56th birthday April the
20th 1945 but Hitler refused to leave
the bunker that very afternoon the
bunker was rocked for the first time by
Soviet bombing loyal to the very ends
Bauman wrote the following in his diary
during those last days in the bunker we
all stand and fall with the Fuhrer loyal
unto death on April the 29th Bauman
became a signatory to Hitler's last will
and testament Hitler also named him as
executor of the estate that evening
Hitler married Eva Braun the next day
the newlyweds committed suicide in
accordance with the Fury's instructions
Bauman was named party Minister making
him the highest ranking Nazi left alive
Admiral Karl dnitz was appointed as the
new president of Germany with Berlin now
in the grip of the enemy and allied
radio station announced that Himmler was
undertaking peace negotiations an
outraged Borman he wrote the following
others believed they must act out of
superior understanding they sacrifice
the Fuhrer shame on them their honor is
disloyalty woman called an emergency
meeting of the top ranking men that were
left in Berlin when the brother-in-law
of Eva Braun General Phelan didn't show
Borman became furious yelling that he
was to be hunted down and arrested
falen was found drunk and in the company
of a woman who was not his wife in his
luggage was found foreign currency he
was returned to the bunker and executed
on borman's orders Borman left the
bunker on May the 1st he was accompanied
by three others their challenge was to
break through the soviet encirclement of
the inner city they made their way to a
u-bahn tunnel which they used to get to
the Spree River Borman was hiding behind
a tank when it was hit by artillery fire
this knocked him to the ground the group
eventually made it across the river one
of them the Hitler Youth Leader Artur
Axmann separated from the others
accident soon saw a Soviet patrol so he
retraced his steps looking across to
where the others had been he saw two
bodies on a bridge he later identified
one of them as being Martin Bormann
later a Red Army left-handed general
claims that he had been brought the
diary of Martin Bormann which had been
found lying in the street by the same
bridge but when men were sent to the
area his body was not found 27 years
later in 1972 the remains of two men
were found by construction workers era
station in West Berlin dental checks
were said to confirm that one of them
was Martin Bormann
however the dentist was working from
memory after a quarter of a century
which casts doubts on the accuracy of
his analysis however the body also had a
collarbone injury which was consistent
with an accident that Borman had
sustained in 1939 both skeletons also
had glass fragments in their jaw bones
which would have been consistent with
them having taken cyanide the West
German authorities deemed these three
pieces of evidence sufficient enough
that they announced that Martin Bormann
was dead the death was confirmed in 1998
when DNA testing was done on fragments
of the skull eleven years later the
remains of Martin Bormann Hitler's
shadow were scattered in the Baltic Sea
so I really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do give us
a thumbs up below don't forget to
subscribe hit that notification bell so
you find out when we put out a new video
also release Jake Ivan Sara watches
you'll find a link to them below and as
always thank you for watching
[Music]